quelque chose d'un peu différent en fait
on a un sac et à l'intérieur de ce sac
est une boisson alors peux pas vous dire
exactement la boisson que c'est pour
l'instant
d'accord on va vous demander de penser
d'imaginer la boisson qui pourrait être
dans le sac
heureusement capa doc gynéco est ok bien
cela c'est un soda chez vous à la maison
non encore chez vous aussi vous pouvez
penser une boisson alors ans et une
boisson ok allez en contre la montre
tu dis à personne ne dit rien du tout de
suite à faire ça mais c'est du sud
d'accord les banques et on va le faire
on va le faire avec kelly qui dit qu'il
va devoir deviner la boisson qui est
dans le sac
j'ai compté jusqu'à 3 et à 3 tu la criée
nom de la boisson tient dans le sac 2,3
vidange complète du jus d'orange
bref ça au testing on avait prévu
sentais que ça allait bien on inverse la
machine à calais
[Applaudissements]
elle avait décidé de vous rappeler à
l'époque j'avais une vidéo qui avait
fait le buzz avec des pop corn et des
téléphones
oui en fait simple on mettait des maïs
sur une table ont posé des téléphones on
appelait les téléphones entrerez en fait
le signal d tellement fort entre les
téléphones la paperasse a sauté comme un
port quand est ce que ça vous dit qu'on
essaie d'expérience mais on a beaucoup
qui disait que c'était des conneries que
c'était une vidéo truquée qu'on essaye
d'accord ce soir on va essayer alors on
se sent on reçoit que des jumeaux parce
qu'elle évoque d'anost derrière aussi
ouais c'est houphouet c'est papa c'est
des manières pour être ce qu'on dise pas
que la table des trucs etc
on va se réveiller tout ça voyez bien
dans mes frères la table et pas du tout
truqués au cas où on est venu près de
connais bien avant qu'on n'a pas les
moyens
d'accord on va faire une petite taille
pour être sûr qu'on dise pas des
magiciens actrice et compagnie pas
m'être levé alors c'est du maïs jeudi au
bureau yo yo comme est très important et
on va avoir besoin de deux téléphones de
personnes va prendre son téléphone cyril
regardez c'est bien le bien c'est voilà
vous dis non pas le signer si tu veux
non merci alors on fait quoi exactement
la même chose on va décaler ça comme ça
nous aidons les personnes là bas je me
tue pas me rend si mon corps sont ici
d'accord ou non merci et d'après moi pas
de regarder bien ses affaires la donne
et c'est début du camp attention c'est
pas on appelle à tous appelés en fait
ah ouais moi j'ai appelé casta mme
houda-pepin soit qu'il m'appelle oui
d'accord c'est comme la canette le tour
et tous les fous tous les tours vous le
font si peur dangereux à l'autochtone
richard
c'est bien les marseillais prennent
éclat dans l'oeil comme sale et au pire
des cas pratiques hassani peut pas
prendre sa fin saint papoul fait messi
ou fedex et martin de tendresse que
prévu c'est tout ce qui était prévu mais
message n'est pas exposé les maïs attend
non non micron chain rapide on s'expose
élevé savons que vous laisser on va vous
laisser sur ça mais je savoure dg
d'orange mais non impossible à arrêter
de casser le canette de coca il vient
d'ouvrir chaude a failli croire non
c'est du jus d'orange à l'art est votre
nom enfin on aura du clic de la canette
rivière
or là
[Applaudissements]
ni son ex était bon de voir débouler
merci ma chérie tu attaques à la
seringue de magie je crois c'est un
samedi mais ça me dirait kamel le
magicien qui est exceptionnel et les
french with voilà qui veut nommer ici
qui veut dire incroyable ils sont
vraiment à chaque fois vous allez aux
états unis moi je me rappelle j'étais
avec une une américaine un moment à
chaque fois que je faisais quelque chose
d'intéressant ghellab a joué gros
célébrant l'arrivée d'hatoyama fait
sérieux coup sur la tête de ma mère
georges les vues en soirée j'étais comme
ça je la vois je la vois l'après midi je
la revois le soir mais c'était prévu
qu'on soit arrivé on avait rendez vous à
l'école à la maison c'est vrai les
américains tapis de feu il se met easing
voilà c'est tout oui ça vous tue nous
l'apprend tenue la première fois la fée
eux-mêmes merci c'est bon je vois que
vous étiez là merci